the UN climate Summit ended in Egypt
with a deal to provide funding for
vulnerable countries as they suffer the
impact of climate change in what's known
as loss and damage but while the talks
were going on in Somalia people were
paying the price for the climate crisis
with their lives the worst drought in 40
years has left millions of people on the
brink of starvation our correspondent
Mariel Muller traveled to baidoa at the
center of the hunger crisis and would
like to warn that this report contains
disturbing images
these children are fighting for their
lives
from all over Somalia those most in need
get referred to this Hospital in the
capital Mogadishu
many die on the way
little Amina Abdi weighs less than half
of what a healthy child her age should
for days she's been in a coma I'm in
Abdi now she she is
unusually normally she was supposed to
be 16 kg she came with Sevilla nutrition
with critical condition with a solid
shock now she is a terminal case
a terminal case at only four years old
this is the impact of the extreme
drought that's devastating Somalia it's
the worst in 40 years
baidoa is 250 kilometers west of the
capital it is seen as the epicenter of
The Hunger crisis
the situation in the hospital here is
desperate
according to the UN a child is being
admitted for medical treatment every
minute famine hasn't been officially
declared yet by the government but a
doctor told me based on the cases
they're seeing the situation now is even
worse than during the last femin 2011
when a quarter of a million people died
one and a half year old Mariam was
admitted a few days ago she's showing
typical symptoms of malnutrition
diarrhea vomiting and whooping cough
for her mother and Aunt the weight is
unbearable
I feel so sad for my sister
I pray to Allah that she will recover
and also that he will alleviate the
drought
like most somalis both were livestock
Farmers until the drought took
everything from them
four rainy seasons have failed and they
are fears that a fifth will Now fail too
High food prices due to the war in
Ukraine decades-long Civil War and
climate change have created an
unprecedented humanitarian disaster Aid
organizations warn millions are on the
brink of starvation
the United Nations Children's Fund
UNICEF says 1 billion US dollars in Aid
is needed to avoid the situation getting
worse we have half a million children
that are severely acutely malnourish
which basically means that if don't if
they don't receive assistance timely
they are just simply going to die 800
000 people have sowed refuge in and
around by door they've doubled the
City's population
says he needs long-term solutions to
deal with the crisis Somalia is one of
the affected areas in in by by the
climate change but what will happen
after the truth and this do we wait
until another farming comes or we we
still come up with with initiatives that
we need to mitigate a future shocks he
expects help from the world's biggest
polluters
while African countries contribute Less
Than 3 percent to climate change they
are among the most vulnerable to its
impact
joining the program now from Nairobi
Kenya is wanjira Mathai the managing
director for Africa and Global
Partnerships at the World Resources
Institute welcome to DW news Africa now
after years of debate the world has
finally agreed on a loss and damage fund
at the just concluded cop 27 Summit in
your eyes is this a game changer
foreign
well thank you for having me first of
all but yes it is a game changer when
you consider that this has been 30 years
in the making a symbol something that
shows an acknowledgment that we have
absolutely differentiated responsibility
with respect to the crisis that climate
is wreaking across this planet so yes it
was a game changer now the formation of
the scheme is still in process but could
you sum up how you would propose that
the system should work
well I certainly would not
work but one some of the principles of
the loss and damage facility and why it
was important to have a loss in damage
facility is surely the swiftness of
action the scale of action look at a
country like Pakistan Nigeria Chad all
of which suffered significant flooding
very quickly and now Kenya and the Horn
of Africa suffering significant droughts
what happens in situations like that the
Frontline communities face the brunt it
is quick it is Fast and the losses and
damages happen pretty relatively fast so
we need something that works quickly
financing that flows in the significant
sums that are required and they flow
swiftly to the countries that need them
so this is the biggest opportunity to
the Gap that that needs to be filled
with respect to financing the modalities
of the fund will be worked through this
the the rest of this year by the
transition committee and so we expect
that a lot of those pieces will be
addressed but swiftness is the biggest
one speaking of swiftness some of the
the wealthy countries are already
failing to deliver on their existing
climate funding pledges so how can we
ensure or even trust that they'll
deliver this time
well this has been the challenge of
course the trust deficits so deep with
the lack of delivery of the 100 billion
for for adaptation but we have to
believe that this is different I was
really encouraged by Simon Steele's
focus in his remarks the the new
executive secretary of the UNF Triple C
that accountability will be his major uh
effort he will place a lot of attention
on delivery and accountability we need
to see accountability that's what
multilateral systems are about let's
just say that we never expected loss and
damage to make it to the agenda a few
years ago it made it on to the agenda
and today we have the decision to create
a financial facility that's significant
I think the rest of it should follow
especially because of what we've seen
with respect to the losses and damages
and that they're not always
geographically related we've seen heat
waves in Europe we've seen forest fires
in North America we've seen a lot of
loss and damage across the board so we
know that this is not
um a unique situation but what we must
acknowledge and what this fund
acknowledges is that the most vulnerable
Among Us are hit harder
and on the on that note of the of the
accountability the payments into the
fund are expected to be voluntary
but on that same note can it be
sustainable if no one actually Bears
responsibility
well I think people are starting to
acknowledge responsibility by creating
this fund we know now with as the
science has gotten tighter the science
of attribution is very clear pollution
in the north is causing an increase in
temperatures and those temperatures are
causing the changes in climate that
we're seeing and wreaking havoc today we
can tell that a storm is climate related
a flood is climate related so
attribution is a lot stronger now so I
don't think we can say it's difficult to
tell what we need is the political will
to acknowledge and take responsibility
that's where the effort should be and
that's where the effort will be okay
when you're up with I thank you very
much for speaking to us